FELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."  VLADIMIR
PUTIN PUTTING ON A PROP GA DATA
SHOW FOR THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE AS
HE BRINGS MORE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION TO UKRAINE.
THE UNHINGED DICTATOR HOLDING A
RALLY IN A MOSCOW STADIUM
BOASTING ABOUT THE SUCCESS OF
HIS INVASION IN UKRAINE DESPITE
MASSIVE LOSS OF RUSSIAN TROOPS.
PUTIN CLAIMING IT WAS JUSTIFIED.
>> THIS IS WHAT GENOCIDE IS ALL
ABOUT.
IT IS PRECISELY TO SAVE PEOPLE
FROM THIS SUFFERING, FROM THIS
GENOCIDE THAT IS THE MAIN REASON
FOR THE MOTIVE AND GOAL OF THE
MILITARY OPERATION THAT WE
LAUNCHED IN THE DANBAS AND
UKRAINE.
>> MIKE TOBIN IS IN LYVIV,
UKRAINE WITH THE LATEST THERE,
MIKE?
>> WELL, JUDGE, THE RELATIVE
PEACE OF THE WESTERN PART OF
THIS COUNTRY WAS SHATTERED AS
THE SIRENS WHALED AND FOUR
CRUISE MISSILES SLAMMED DOWN
PERILOUSLY CLOSE TO THE EASTERN
FLANK, THE TARGET OF THE AIR
STRIKES IS THE LYVIV AIRCRAFT
REPAIR SO IT COULD BE USED BY
THE UKRAINIAN AIR FORCE.
THE ADMINISTRATOR OF LYVIV SAYS
SIX CRUISE MISSILES WERE
LAUNCHED OVER THE BLACK SEA BY
LONG RANGE BOMBERS.
TWO INTERCEPTED, FOUR MADE THEIR
WAY TO THE TARGET.
THE X555s WERE THE PRICE TAG
AROUND $1 MILLION APIECE.
IT'S A DESPERATE SITUATION
DOWN SOUTH IN THE TOWN AFTER
MARIUPOL WHERE THE DONETSK WAS
USED AS A BOMB SHELTER.
IT WAS MARKED THERE WERE
CHILDREN INSIDE.
IT WAS HIT BY RUSSIAN AIRCRAFT
ANYWAY.
1,000 PEOPLE WERE INSIDE ON BOTH
THE FIRST FLOOR AND IN THE
BASEMENT.
WE GOT REPORTS YESTERDAY THAT
SOME PEOPLE GOT OUT.
TODAY WE ARE HEARING FROM A
POLITICIAN DOWN THERE THAT THE
RESCUERS ATTEMPTING TO FREE THE
PEOPLE TRAP IN THE RUBBLE ARE
BEING FIRED UPON BY THE RUSSIAN
FORCES AND CANNOT EVEN GET TO
THE  WRECKAGE TO GET PEOPLE OUT
OR DETERMINE THE EXTENT OF THE
TRAGEDIES.
MARIUPOL IS A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
ARE RESORTING TO MASS GRAVES
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT HANDLE THE
LOGISTICS OF HOW MANY DEAD THEY
HAVE ON THEIR HANDS.
THE PEOPLE IN THAT TOWN ARE
LEAVING.
BUT THE HUMANITARIAN CORRIDORS,
THEY SAY, ARE NOT HOLDING
TOGETHER.
THE PEOPLE ARE DESPERATE ENOUGH
THAT THEY ARE FLEEING UNDER
FIRE, QUITE LITERALLY, RUNNING
FOR THEIR LIVES.
JUDGE?
>> MIKE, THANKS SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS, YOU KNOW THE
JUXTAPOSITION OF THE MASS GRAVES
AND THE KILLING OF CHILDREN AND
THE INABILITY OF PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW, TO EVEN WAIT IN LINE
WITHOUT GETTING IN A BREAD LINE
WITHOUT GETTING SHOT, IT JUST
AMAZING.
SO YOU ALWAYS HEARD ABOUT PUTIN
HIDING.
NOW HE'S OUT WITH 2,000 PEOPLE
IN AND AROUND THAT STADIUM.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, IS HE
COPYING ZELENSKY NOW, OR DO YOU
THINK HE NEEDED TO SHORE UP
SUPPORT?
DOES HIS COUNTRY -- DOES HE NEED
TO LET THEM KNOW THEY'RE IN
CHARGE?
>> THE ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CRIMEAN INVASION.
SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE A BIG RALLY.
IT WAS A FAKE RALLY.
THE BBC HAD A TEAM OF REPORTERS
INSIDE.
AND THERE WERE PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEES TO GO THERE BY THEIR
EMPLOYERF A BUNCH OF YOUNGER
PEOPLE WERE TOLD THEY DIDN'T
KNOW WHERE THEY WERE GOING.
THEY SAID WE'RE GOING TO SEND
YOU TO THE CONCERT.
THEY SAID YOU CAN GO TO THE
CONCERT IF YOU CAN HAVE OFF FOR
THE DAY.
THEY FOUND OUT IT WAS A PUTIN
RALLY.
ONE GUY SAID I'LL BE HERE FOR A
WHILE AND THEN I WILL LEAVE.
MOST PEOPLE HERE DON'T SUPPORT
THE WAR, I DON'T.
MOST PEOPLE FELT ASHAMED AND
EMBARRASSED TO BE THERE.
SO, I DO FEEL BAD FOR THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE.
IT'S LIKE HAVING YOUR FATHER BE
A CAREER CRIMINAL.
IT'S HUMILIATING AND NOTHING YOU
CAN DO ABOUT IT.
NOW HE'S GOING OUT THERE AND
ACTING LIKE IT'S 1945 AND LYING
HIS WAY THROUGH A WAR IN 2022.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
YOU CAN'T LIE ABOUT A WAR IN
THIS DAY AND AGE.
IT'S JUST IMPOSSIBLE.
AND HOW HUMILIATING MUST IT BE
FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN TO HAVE TO
TELL ALL THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM,
THESE ARE THE LIES WE'RE GOING
TO TELL AND YOU HAVE TO TASTE MY
FOOD BECAUSE I'M SO PARANOID,
YOU ALL HATE ME, I THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO KILL ME.
THAT'S AN INSANE WAY TO RUN A
COUNTRY.
HE MUST BE A COMPLETE PSYCHOPATH
TO RULE A NATION IN THIS DAY AND
AGE LIKE THAT.
>> WELL, ANYONE SAYS THEY'RE
GOING TO DEMILITARIZE A COUNTRY
BECAUSE OF NAZIISM WHEN THE
PRESIDENT IS JEWISH IS NOT SO --
>> PREPOSTEROUS.
>> BUT, DAGUEN, I WANT TO ASK
YOU THIS.
WHEN HE WAS SPEAKING TO THAT
CROWD, HE QUOTED THE BIBLE.
HE TALKED ABOUT RUSSIA
PREVAILING.
AND, YOU KNOW, AGAINST A NATION
WITHOUT NAZIISM.
AND HE STIRS UP THIS RUSSIAN
NATIONALISM.
DOES THIS SUGGEST HE IS IN ALL
THE WAY TO THE END?
THERE'S NO WAY -- HE'S NOT
STOPPING.
AND THAT IT'S A FIGHT TO THE
FINISH?
>> THE ONLY WAY THIS ENDS
QUICKLY IS IF SOMETHING HAPPENS
TO PUTIN.
LIKE A BRAIN ANEURYSM.
I'M NOT JOKING AND I'M NOT GOING
TO TALK ABOUT -- I'M GOING TO
USE THE WORD "ASSASSINATION" BUT
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY IT ENDS.
SINCE THE ANNEXATION OF CRY MIA,
THE RUBLE HAS FALLEN SINCE THE
SANCTIONS.
IT HASN'T COME BACK.
RUSSIANS ARE POOR, THERE'S VISA
RESTRICTIONS.
THERE'S LESS PROSPERITY IN THE
COUNTRY.
BUT YOU STILL -- THEIR FIDELITY
TO PUTIN, PARTICULARLY AMONG
OLDER RUSSIANS, HAS NOT
COMPLETELY BEEN SHAKEN BECAUSE
RUSSIA, SINCE PUTIN TOOK OVER,
IT WAS A CLEPTOCRACY AFTER THE
SOVIET UNION.
IT WAS RULED BY CRIMINALS.
YOU WOULD GET SHOT IN THE
STREETS.
RUSSIA IS IN BETTER SHAPE THAN
IT WAS.
AND THERE IS A DEEP NATIONALISM.
AND A WILLINGNESS TO ENDURE AND
SUFFER.
AGAIN, STARBUCKS CLOSING IS NOT
A HARDSHIP IN RUSSIA.
IN TERMS OF -- I DON'T WANT TO
GET TOO OFF TRACK.
BUT THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE ARE IN
PART CUT OFF FROM INFORMATION
BECAUSE OF OUR TECHNOLOGY
GRADES, GOOGLE AND APPLE.
THEY CAVED TO PUTIN LAST FALL.
THEY WERE WILDLY IGNORANT OF
WHAT HE WAS CAPABLE OF.
AND THEY, GOOGLE AND APPLE GOT
THREATS FROM PUTIN'S -- HIS
STRONG MEN.
AND THEY TOOK DOWN AN APP THAT
WAS DESIGNED TO GET RUSSIANS TO
REGISTER PROTEST VOTES AGAINST
PUTIN THAT WAS BACKED BACK
OPPOSITION LEADER ALEXI NOVANI.
APPLE STARTED TO CONFIGURE I
PHONES TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
PROMOTE KREMLIN-BACKED SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES.
ALSO IN RUSSIA, YOU DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE APPLE SECURITY
TOOL.
IT'S A FEATURE DESIGNED TO MAKE
IT UNDETECTABLE.
SO MUCH FOR THE FREEDOM OF THE
TECHNOLOGY.
>> ALL RIGHT, GREG, ONE PERSON
WHO'S GOTTEN OUTSIDE OF THAT IS
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER.
TAKE A LISTEN --
>> NEVER HEARD OF HIM.
>> UKRAINE DID NOT START THIS
WAR?
NEITHER DID NATIONALISTS OR
NAZIS.
THOSE IN POWER IN THE KREMLIN
STARTED THIS WAR.
THIS IS NOT THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE'S
WAR.
THIS IS AN ILLEGAL WAR.
YOUR LIVES, YOUR LIMBS, YOUR
FUTURES ARE BEING SACRIFICED FOR
A SENSELESS WAR CONDEMNED BY THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
>> BEST WORK SINCE CONAN, I
THINK.
I'M NOT -- I'M NOT KIDDING.
YOU KNOW, I THOUGHT IT WAS
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
IT WAS VERY PERSUASIVE.
IT WAS INCREDIBLY WELL WRITTEN.
AND IT WAS ALSO -- WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS IDEA OF FACE
SAVING AND STATUS PRESERVATION.
AND THAT'S WHAT HE DID FOR NINE
MINUTES WHEN HE WAS TALKING TO
THE RUSSIANS AND TALKING TO
PUTIN BECAUSE PUTIN FOLLOWS HIM
ON TWITTER.
HE HAS 22 IN ONE OF THEM.
SO IF YOU HAVE TO TALK WITH THE
COUNTRY WITH A DEEP HISTORY, YOU
UH HAVE TO TALK ABOUT YOU'RE A
GREAT PEOPLE.
I LOVE YOU.
HE WAS SO POLITEF AND HE
REFERENCED HIS OWN FLAWS.
DAD'S A NAZI, WOOPS.
HE WENT OVERBOARD ON JANUARY 6,
BUT HE DID THAT -- NOT FOR US.
HE DID IT FOR RUSSIA TO SAY,
HEY, LOOK, WE HAVE OUR PROBLEMS
TOO.
AND I'M GOING TO CALL OUT
JANUARY, BUT I'M GOING TO CALL
OUT THIS AS WELL.
SO, I THOUGHT IT WAS PERSUASIVE.
SO I GO AND TEXT ALANA, MY WIFE.
SHE'S IN WARSAW.
I GO, HEY, WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
THAT.
SHE SAID IT WAS GREAT.
THE THING THAT SHE LOVED ABOUT
IT WAS IT WAS POLITE BECAUSE IT
MADE HER CRY IN A WAY -- IT WAS
HOW NAIVE WE ARE TO THINK IT
WOULD MATTER.
AND I GO, YOU DON'T THINK IT
WOULD MOVE THE NEEDLE OR HAVE AN
IMPACT.
SHE JUST RESPONDED WITH A
NUMBER OF LAUGHING EMOJIS AND A
CAPITALIZED "NO."  AND I GO,
THIS KIND OF THING, WE BELIEVE
AS AMERICANS HAS AN IMPACT.
THAT'S THE BEST CELEBRITY VIDEO
YOU'RE GOING TO GET WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
BUT RUSSIA -- THEY DIDN'T GROW
UP WITH FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
THEY DON'T -- THEY DON'T HAVE --
THAT'S THE THING THAT'S NOT IN
THEIR BLOOD.
SO WHETHER THIS HAS AN IMPACT ON
THEM AND PERSUADES THEM, I DON'T
KNOW.
THE PEOPLE IT DOES PERSUADE ARE
THERE.
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET, SOCIAL MEDIA.
THEY GET IT.
BUT IN TERMS OF EVERYBODY ELSE?
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT I STILL THOUGHT -- I HAVE
FRIENDS OF MINE WHO THINK IT'S
GOING TO HAVE A BIG IMPACT. BUT
THE RUSSIANS WHO ARE, TO USE
YOUR PHRASE -- WHAT DID YOU
WRITE?
ASHAMED AND EMBARRASSED?
THEY ARE ALL ASHAMED AND
EMBARRASSED.
AND THEY'RE SO PESSIMISTIC.
YOU KNOW, I GO, THIS IS GREAT.
THEY'RE GOING, GREG, IT'S --
IT'S -- IT'S TOO LATE.
YOU KNOW?
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
THEY'RE SICKENED.
OF.
>> ALL RIGHT, IF THE WEST IS
SERIOUS ABOUT STOPPING PUTIN AND
HIS SO-CALLED STOPPING OF
GENOCIDE IN THE UKRAINE AND THE
CELEBRATION OF TAKING CRIMEA,
HOW CAN THEY DO IT?
>> WELL, IT SEEMS THAT THEY ARE
MAKING PRETTY GOOD HEADWAY HERE.
I MEAN, EVERYTHING YOU HEAR OUT
OF THIS, NOT OUT OF PUTIN'S
MOUTH, BUT EVERYONE ELSE'S
MOUTH, U.S. INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS, UK, THE POLES, WHAT
YOU HEAR FROM THE UKRAINIANS,
ZELENSKY AND HIS TEAM, THEY THEY
ARE HOLDING RUSSIANS AT BAY.
THEY HAVE LOST THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
HE HAS COMMITTED WAR CRIMES.
THOSE ARE HUGE TRAVESTIES.
BUT IF YOU THINK BACK OF HOW
PETRIFIED WE WERE ABOUT THAT
CONVOY.
NINE MILES LONG, 13 MILES LONG.
AND NOW IT'S NOTHING, RIGHT?
WE DON'T HEAR ABOUT THAT
ANYMORE.
WHAT HAPPENED IN MARIOPUL, WHICH
I HOPE I PRONOUNCED.
HUGE TRAGEDY.
THE PRIME MINISTER SAID WE'RE
REBUILDING THAT HOSPITAL BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THE LARGEST APT OF
GREEKS ARE IN UKRAINE.
YOU SEE OTHER PRIME MINISTERS
COMING IN FROM NATO COUNTRIES
SITTING WITH ZELENSKY IN KYIV,
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
WHEN I SAW PUTIN, HE WAS A MAN
ALONE.
HE HAS NO ALLIES STANDING NEXT
TO HIM.
FOUR OR FIVE COUNTRIES TO BACK
HIM UP.
HE COULDN'T GET THE CHECHEN
LEADER TO SHOW UP AND STAND
THERE WITH HIM.
HE COULDN'T G GET PEOPLE FROM
THE FORMER USSR.
AND, I -- I DON'T WANT TO SAY I
FEEL GOOD ABOUT DEMOCRACY'S
CHANCES HERE.
BUT IT REALLY DOES FEEL LIKE
IT'S THE ENTIRE WORLD AGAINST
THIS MAN.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO.
WHY THE RHETORIC OF THE VIDEO
LIKE ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER MADE
COULDN'T MATTER IS DECOUPLING
FROM PUTIN IS THE RHETORICAL
TRICK HERE.
HE IS NOT REPRESENTING NATIONAL
INTEREST.
THESE ARE PEOPLE REPRESSED FROM
THE GET-GO.
WE HAVE TO TURN THE TIDE ON
THAT.
EVERY LITTLE BIT.
SOMEONE SEES THAT VIDEO AND
PASSES IT TO THEIR MOMS AND
ACTIVATES THOSE MOMS -- THE
RUSSIAN MOTHERS HAVE PLAYED A
HUGELY IMPORTANT ROLE IN KEEPING
RUSSIA ON A GOOD PATH.
AND NOW THAT THEY ARE GETTING A
CHANCE TO FACE TIME THEIR KIDS
WHO HAVE BEEN SENT OVER TO
UKRAINE NOT KNOWING WHERE
THEY'RE GOING, I HOPE TO SEE
MORE OF THAT KIND OF ACTIVITY.
>> YOU NEED TO DECOUPLE PUTIN
FROM THE MONEY THAT'S FUNDING
THE WAR.
>> THE SANCTIONS ARE HUGELY
EFFECTIVE.
WE CAN DO MORE.
>> 2/ OF RUSSIA'S ECONOMY IS NOT
SANCTIONED.
NOT ANY ENERGY TRANSACTIONS.
THAT'S ON EUROPE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK IS IMPORTANT IS SOMETHING
YOU MENTIONED.
THAT WILL IS, IS WE HAVE THREE
NATO LEADS WITH ZELENSKY RIGHT
NOW IN KYIV.
IF WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE THOSE
THREE NATO LEADERS, JUST, YOU
KNOW, MORE LEADERS EVERY DAY
ALONG WITH THE PATRIARCH FROM
THE RUSSIAN ORTHODOX RELIGIOUS
COMMUNITY, FROM THE GREEK
ORTHODOX RELIGIOUS COMMUNITY,
STAND THERE WITH ZELENSKY, WITH
ALL OF NATO, ALL OF THE
RELIGIOUS LEADERS, THAT WOULD
HAVE A PROFOUND EFFECT ON THE
WORLD IN TERMS OF THIS IS
DIPLOMACY, YOU'RE GOING TO BOMB
US, YOU'RE GOING TO BOMB THE
CHURCHES AND THE LEADERS OF
NATO.
WE DARE YOU.
>> AND THEN YOU'RE GOING TO GET
YOUR NUCLEAR WAR.
>> WE'LL SEE.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> ANYWAY, COMING UP; PRESIDENT